we begin this morning with the
continuing fallout from the firing of
FBI director james comey yesterday
President Trump tweeted a veiled threat
at the former director not to talk to
the news media that has prompted charges
that he's trying to silence the man who
was leading the investigation of
possible collusion between Trump's
campaign and Russia in that tweet mr.
Trump appeared to suggest his
conversations with Comey could have been
taped the president speaks today at
commencement at the Christian school
Liberty University in Lynchburg Virginia
that's where we find Errol Barnett Errol
good morning good morning yes president
Trump has been politically bruised after
a remarkable week in which his
administration struggled to explain why
the director of the FBI was fired but in
making his case on television and on
Twitter Friday the president appears to
have opened new self-inflicted wounds
that I can't talk about I won't talk
about that President Trump told Fox News
he would not discuss the possibility his
conversations with former FBI director
James Comey may have been recorded as he
suggested in this Friday tweet quote
James Comey better hope that there are
no tapes of our conversations before he
starts leaking to the press all I want
is for coming to be honest and I hope he
will be and I'm sure he will be I hope
top Democrats on the House Oversight and
Judiciary Committees and now requesting
copies of all recordings in possession
of the White House in this letter sent
to the administration's legal counsel
like many Democrats senator Tim Kaine is
suspicious President Trump is fired this
guy because the the dragnet tightening
on the Russia investigation but the
president told NBC News Comey was fired
because of how he handled the Hillary
Clinton email investigation what
happened he had a lot of pressure put on
and he exonerated her should have never
exonerated her mr. Trump also disputes
reports that at a dinner in January he
asked Comey for his loyalty Comey told
associates he declined the President's
request instead saying he would always
be honest did you as a class know no I
didn't but
I don't think it would be a bad question
asked I think loyalty to the country
loyalty to the United States is
important you know I mean it depends on
how you define not loyalty number one
number two I don't know how that got
there because I didn't ask that question
the shifting explanations from the White
House for commis firing led the
President to suggest getting rid of
press briefings altogether what you just
don't have them unless I have one every
two weeks and I do myself we don't have
them part of the reason the president
said there is unfair hostility toward
his spokespeople by press secretary Sean
Spicer I think he's a little dismayed as
well as a lot of people that we come out
here and try to do everything we can to
provide you in the American people with
what he's doing on their behalf the
White House also released a letter from
mr. Trump's private lawyers Friday in an
attempt to answer questions about
alleged connections between Trump
associates and Russia the letter which
only covers the past decade reads quote
with a few exceptions your tax returns
do not reflect any income of any type
from Russian sources now the Acting
Director of the FBI Andrew McCabe said
that he does have the agency has the
resources it needs to complete the
Russia investigation although one senior
source tells CBS News that there has
been some interference and today the
Department of Justice will interview
possible replacements for Co me
including McCabe and Texas Senator John
Cornyn Anthony Errol Barnett in
Lynchburg Virginia thanks Errol